I think there is a lot of value in
talking about your ex in a favorable way
I have to say
when I first got divorced many years ago
I went on on a date with a young woman
it's one of my first dates as a divorced
man
and she was a divorced woman
she's a beautiful woman
and we were having dinner and it was
going quite well and it was one of those
things where I was like oh I definitely
want to see this girl again
and I said something about oh you know
there's going to be this thing at this
Museum we should go and she's like oh
yeah that'd be a lot of fun and I'm like
yeah we should definitely you know maybe
the next thing we do together and she
was like yeah we should go next weekend
like the kids are with the so we
can go and and I just it was like you
could hear that record scratch like you
know I just went oh yeah no this isn't
good like I'm not you're referring to
the father your kids is it the
like we're like we're already I'm
walking into something here that I don't
know that I want to be involved in
Matthew McConaughey before he was
married
you know if you look at his history he
dated some of the most beautiful women
in Hollywood in their Prime
and none of them
ever talked bad about him in the Press
they all were like oh my God he's such a
great guy such great and I always
wondered like
how do you he got out of all of those
relationships without a without a
scratch on him and when you'd watch an
interview with him
they would say like so you you know you
dated Penelope Cruz and he'd go
Penelope that's just that's just a
special lady that was just a what a what
a special lady she's just a wonderful
what a wonderful woman
are just so blessed to have the time
with her what a beautiful wonderful
woman and and I would think to myself
I'm like I'm like you're a genius like
he's a genius because like it it he
never came off as Petty spiteful bitter
any of that he just came off as like
just dignified strong smart self-assured
and like it left
you know it left like it it left the the
viewer
with the impression that like when he
was looking off and specifically he's
probably like just thinking about some
wonderful time he had with her and you
think to yourself like God that guy like
he just became cooler and cooler whereas
if he got into like the whole you know
oh yeah that was ugly and then you know
this happened and that like nobody wants
to hear it it's awful the funny thing
about him just having to interact with a
little bunch I don't think he's in the
he's in the Rogan school of thought I
think that I don't see him ever having a
fight
now his parents were as he as he's
spoken about a bunch non-stop fighting
they got divorced and remarried and yeah
just insane and they were volatile yeah
very and he seems maybe you kind of uh
it depends on swinging the other way he
just seems cool as a cucumber like
always just lets it roll off yeah but
you know even if it's internally yeah
not rolling off
there is value
in just Rising above it in your
discourse
that's true yes like like you lie to
your children like people say this to me
all the time clients they're like
you know why did you tell your child
that Dad had an affair well I'm not
gonna lie to my kids
you yes you are you lie to your
kids all the time yeah Mommy are you
gonna die someday yes Bae I'm gonna die
and daddy's gonna die and then someday
the Earth's gonna hurl into the Sun and
we're all gonna die sweet dreams like
that's not you lie to your kids all the
time you know what's wrong with me we
don't know what's wrong with you we're
gonna take you to the doctor and
hopefully it's nothing serious and you
won't die like you lie to your kids all
the time you tell them that Santa Claus
exists when he does whatever
to so so to say I'm not gonna lie to my
kids like you lie to your kids all the
time you don't like your husband that's
okay
you don't like your ex-husband but it's
their father so just grin you know Oh
Daddy took me to meet his new girlfriend
Kiki oh that's nice you guys have a good
time good oh that's yeah and she helped
me do my hair and she did my makeup
listen I'm sure that's burning you
inside
but you go oh that's great because why
you love you kids well that's what I
mean again mcconnie has a as a way about
him with that he's like he basically
says never lie but a little is
okay sure sure